frankfurt in germany hosted the third of
the european parliament's rotating react
conferences
after the round unemployment this time
it was the turn of european values and
how they should be funded which was in
the hot seat for the public debate
but what is the added value for member
states of investment in the eu budget
what about the place of solidarity our
country is shelling out too much money
to the eu
experts researchers and economists
exchange their ideas and views
this wide-ranging debate is open to all
citizens
if you can't make it in person to the
react conferences they are all
accessible via social media
so you won't miss a thing next up rome
and then it's off to madrid from january
2014.
sports has wound up in the parliament
limelight but sadly it's not for fair
play
match fixing and corruption in sports
events was the focus of the european
parliament's hearings
legal experts and those from the world
of sports had the chance to take stock
of the outbreak of this problem
all called for a harmonization of
sanctions
since august 2013 it is alleged that
more than 50 football matches were fixed
and suspicions also weigh over 150
others